national security correspondent jennifer
griffin is at the pentagon tonight with
the latest good evening jennifer good
evening brett as putin's forces face
setbacks many u.s officials worry he may
be pushed to use more lethal weapons
that could cause large-scale civilian
casualties like these thermobaric
weapons vacuum bombs known as the father
of all bombs which generate high
temperatures that can start fires and
burn everyone and everything within its
blast radius they were used in chechnya
this footage is from 2014. u.s officials
assess the russians have moved to
launcher systems for thermobaric weapons
into ukraine but not the weapon itself a
grisly symbol of putin's desire to wipe
ukraine off the map his army is
targeting cultural sites and in a sick
twist after the russian leader spoke of
denazifying ukraine the russian military
bombed the holocaust memorial in kiev a
reminder that nothing is off limits here
is the moment that president zielinski
who is jewish was told by his chief of
staff the memorial known as babinyar was
bombed
president i'd like to inform that now
it's bombing
my congratulations
u.s defense officials are watching the
slow progress of the 40-mile convoy
coming to kiev reasons it may be stalled
the russians still don't have enough gas
and have run out of food reports suggest
some russian soldiers are punching holes
in their own fuel tanks to stop their
vehicles from moving forward u.s
officials say they have no reason to
doubt those reports some russian
soldiers have surrendered even without a
fight many are conscripts not told why
they were there
then there is the high-tech help sent
from outside ukraine elon musk delivered
a satellite internet service shown here
called starlink hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else